[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
singular value decomposition and how we
can take data matrices and decompose
them into dominant column eyes
correlation vectors and dominant row
wise correlation vectors and so now I'm
going to walk you through an example in
MATLAB I want to point out that this
entire lecture series is from chapter
one of our new book data-driven science
and engineering by myself and Nathan
cuts and all of the code in both MATLAB
and in Python are online at this website
I realize you can't probably see this
the website is data book UW comm and we
have all of the MATLAB code here and
then all of the Python code was
translated by Daniel Toulouse key so you
can code in whichever framework you like
and there's also the lectures in each of
these parts for each of these chapters
so chapter 1 is the first chapter in
part 1 on the singular value
decomposition and so on and so forth ok
so all of the code is here this is what
we're gonna be following and today I'm
going to walk you through the first
example of how to compute the SVD on a
simple image example alright and we're
going to invert our colors to make our
lives a little bit easier so things look
look a little bit cleaner ok so we're
gonna walk through a lot of examples in
both MATLAB and in Python of how to
compute the SVD and how to use it this
is really kind of just a warm-up where
we're going to load an image of my dog
mort and we're going to use the SVD to
compress that image and we're going to
look at how the compression quality
varies as we keep more or less modes
remember this is useful for matrix
approximation so we're going to
approximate a matrix which is an image
ok good so the first thing I'm going to
do is clear all of my memory close all
of the windows and clear the screen and
so the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to load the image of my dog so
I'm going to load it into this matrix a
image read dog dot jpg
I think that should work and it's a
color image so I'm going to convert it
into a grayscale image x equals double
RGB to gray of a so I'm going to convert
this from an into 256 color image into
double valued so double precision
numbers only in greyscale channels I'm
going to collapse all of the color
channels into one I should probably show
you what this actually looks like so I'm
just gonna do an image SC actually maybe
I'll make some subplots subplot two to
one so I'm going to have a four by four
image the first one is going to be the
true dog and then I'm going to show
different compressed versions of morte
so two to one image SC x-axis off and
because I've inverted my color scheme
normally I would use color map gray I
have a custom color map gray inverse
where I just flip the color values so
I'm going to do color map gray in that's
my own code I wrote and then I'm gonna
put a title original that's my original
dog okay and hopefully nothing okay
that's a little tiny so what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to set the GCF position
let's say 1200 by 1600 okay good
so this is Mordecai the snow dog this is
the original high-res image you can zoom
in and it's it's very high res image and
what we're gonna do is we're gonna treat
this grayscale image as if it were a
matrix okay so this is a big matrix I
don't know if you can see here but it's
size 52,000 by 1500 s so two thousand
rows 1500 columns so a high resolution
image and we're going to use the SVD to
compress that X matrix okay so that's
what we're gonna do in MATLAB to compute
the SVD is extremely simple you just say
u sv
SVD of my ex matrix and I'm gonna give
it the economy option because I don't
want big square matrices of size 2000 by
2004 you
I want a 2000 by 1500 u matrix of just
the first 1,500 singular vectors
corresponding to the nonzero singular
values okay so very easy and I should
definitely put a semicolon on this
because if I don't it's just going to
dump all of those matrices to the to the
screen so I can run this and it takes
very little time to run it's done but I
think what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to switch to a version where I
actually have some of this coded up okay
so this is what we just coded we have
our image of Mort loaded here we compute
the SVD u Sigma V equals SVD of X and I
should be careful and put the econ it
doesn't really matter that much for this
matrix because it's almost square but if
it was a skinnier matrix this would make
a bigger deal and now what I'm gonna do
in this code right here I'm going to go
through different ranks of the SVD
truncation so remember we can use the
SVD we have this x equals u Sigma V
transpose and what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to look at the approximation of
that that SVD if I only keep the first
are columns of U the first r by r sub
block of Sigma and the first are columns
of V and then transposed and so we're
going to look at what the image
reconstruction looks like for rank five
rank 20 and rank 100 okay so we're going
to increase the matrix approximation and
we should do a better and better job and
to build the matrix approximation is
pretty simple I just take those first
are columns of U times the first r by r
sub block if sigma times the first are
columns of V transposed and that's X
approximate and then I plot it okay
that's what we're gonna do here I'm
going to run this good that's mort then
I'm going to run this code
and here are my my matrix approximations
my low-rank SVD approximations so again
my original high resolution dog this is
more if you only keep the first five
dominant singular vectors left and right
singular vectors and this is as you
increase to order 20 and order 100
okay so let's break this down in this R
equals 5 case we essentially are
approximating this entire image by 5
linearly independent columns and 5
linearly independent rows and you can
tell that there's a lot of loss in this
in this compression but it actually has
a lot of the basic features of the dog
so you can see kind of the snout the
eyes the ears and even the stripes on
his on his Pelt ok so that's you know
even just 5 modes gets at least the
rough idea of a dog and as you increase
this to R equals 20 and R equals 100 you
can see that you get a lot more of the
subtle features so it's it's maybe a
little hard to tell in low resolution
but you can tell that this is definitely
a dog you can even tell kind of what
type of dog but you can't see really the
high resolution and the eyes for example
or crisp details of the tail but as you
increase the number of modes to a
hundred modes you actually start very
faithfully reproducing this dog March ok
a couple of other neat things about
image compression with the SVD so this
isn't you know that widely used people
usually use Fourier transforms or
wavelets and what's called JPEG
compression which we'll talk about later
but this is actually a massive
compression of the data so remember that
my original X matrix is 2,000 by 1500
whereas here I only have to keep a
hundred of those vectors and a hundred
of those row vectors so 100 column
vectors and a hundred row vectors this
is almost a it's almost a 15 to 1
compression in in this actually I guess
I have the numbers up here this is
exactly 11 point 6 7 percent of the
numbers of X have to be stored to keep
the first hundred columns of U the first
columns of V and the first hundred 100
matrix of Sigma okay so you can actually
explicitly compute how much compression
or how much data you're storing here's
0.6% here's 2.3 percent and here is
11.7%
so pretty good compression and you
faithfully reconstruct the dog as
something else I'll point out in
actually a lot of times an image
compression what you can do is you can
embed digital watermarks in very very
low singular vectors of the data matrix
so if you want to copyright this image
and say image this was taken by my wife
image by Bing Brenton what you could do
is you could pick a really really really
low Sigma value and you could build
essentially some digital watermark with
some some information in the U and the V
columns and you could add that onto this
this matrix it won't change what you
actually see in the pixel values but
then if you take the SVD of this matrix
that digital watermark will still be in
that low the low value singular singular
values and singular vectors so you can
kind of hide information in those low
energy modes if you wanted to okay
digital watermarking good so a couple of
other things I want to show you are
actually plotting the singular values so
this is extremely important anytime you
have a data matrix X and you compute its
SVD I strongly encourage you to plot the
singular values in Sigma okay this tells
you how many modes you need to keep what
the structure of your data is if it's
high rank or low rank and how how you
can get away with truncating at the
value of R okay so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna plot the diagonal
elements of Sigma remember it's a
diagonal matrix so I only want to plot
the diagonal elements and I'm gonna plot
them on a semi-log Y plot so I'm gonna
only take the logarithm of those values
and I'm going to plot them and then I'm
also gonna plot the cumulative sum so
the sum of the first are singular values
divided by the sum of all of the
singular values to see how much energy
or how much information is in the first
are modes compared to all of the nodes
okay and that's a lot to say but I'll
show you what it looks like
okay so these are the singular value
plots for Mort the snow dog and you see
that on the x-axis here we have the
increasing rank from R equals 1 to 1500
and on the Left plot we're plotting the
logarithm of the singular value Sigma
and so what you can see is that there's
actually a very very steep drop-off in
the magnitude of these singular values
and then eventually it kind of levels
off and so this is what we're looking
for is this kind of large group of big
singular values that keeps most of the
information in the data matrix and that
tells me that I can probably throw away
a lot of these low energy singular
values and keep most of the information
in my data matrix you can in principle
you know do all kinds of things you can
you know figure out how much you can be
quantitative about this you can figure
out exactly how much drop-off there is
in the first 10 20 50 hundred modes and
so on and so forth and then over here in
the cumulative energy I think this is
also a really important and interesting
way to plot is if I only kept the first
let's say hundred or 500 modes how much
of the cumulative energy would I keep in
that data set and so you can tell that
here were over 90% if we keep the first
500 modes surprisingly even with the
first one mode we get about 30% of the
information in that data matrix so 30%
of that matrix is kind of rank 1 and
then you just keep doing better and
better as you increase the rank R okay
good so we'll have more principal
discussions on how to select the rank R
later in in later sections but I just
wanted to show you this you always plot
this every time you compute a singular
value decomposition you plot the semi
log Y of the singular values and the
cumulative sum to see how much energy or
variance you get a train car ok good and
then the last thing I'm going to show
you is this interpretation of the SVD in
terms of so the U and the V columns are
eigen vectors of correlation matrices
between the rows and the columns of X so
this is what we'll talk about next is if
I compute these correlation matrices x
times X prime and sorry x times X
transpose
prime here just means transpose in
MATLAB so this is xx transpose and X
transpose X if I computed the
eigenvectors of those big square
matrices I would get the columns of U
and V and the eigenvalues of those
correlation matrices would be the
related to the diagonal elements of
Sigma so I'm just gonna plot what these
look like that's a little small so I'm
going to plot it up here on the same one
and so you can tell that there's a lot
of structure in these correlation
matrices so if I looked at the
eigenvectors and eigenvalues of these
correlation matrices I would essentially
get the dominant rows and the dominant
columns of my my SVD of my dog boards
okay good so we've done an image
compression example on Mort on a matrix
X just to show how easy it is to compute
the SVD in matlab and work with it okay
thank you